well from one new art exhibit to another
the bellagio gallery of fine art
giving locals and tourists an exhibit to
visit with a variety of art from notable
las vegas collectors we have rocky theas
joining us there live to give us a
preview hi rocky
okay yes so i'm here and i was looking
at this one and i thought
that's actually relevant to the times
right theresa it is very relevant for
the time
let's introduce everybody to this one
here nurse in las vegas this is an
artwork by richard prince
and he does a series of nurses and this
one happens to be las vegas nurse
um so it's quite fitting that it is in
this show um as it's part of a
collection from las vegas as well
right we're happy to have her here and
to definitely abide by our
by our rules yeah honoring our everyday
heroes and speaking of that how do we do
an art exhibit safely during this time i
know that is this is actually you know a
very open space easily social distance
right
it is and yes i mean we require mass
when you enter in bellagio as well as
into the art gallery
and we it's easily to stay socially
distanced within the gallery there's
plenty of space
to move around and enjoy the artwork
while still see you know following
safety
all right well then let's move around
let's enjoy the artwork let's go into
this room here i love this one there is
an original picasso
two of them here that you can see for
yourself where can else can you do that
throughout the bellagio but you also get
a lot of really cool pieces
in here as well so let's talk about this
picasso
in particular yes this picasso is also
from the 1940s we have another work in
the exhibit too
from the 1940s why picasa was living in
nazi occupied paris wow where can you
actually see a picasso
with your own eyes it's so incredible
these colors just pop off of the wall
um speaking of color this one here is
one of my favorites and teresa i want to
talk about other than
the art being the star of this show it's
also about the collectors right
it is we really wanted to focus on um
the passion of collecting and what that
means to live with artworks that you
purchase and have in your own home
right um or in your office and you see
them every day so that must really mean
that you
support the artist and support that
period of their artwork what they're
doing
so that's what we really wanted to focus
on is that you know getting these pieces
that are near and dear to these
collectors
and are there any names we could throw
out i know elaine nguyen has one in here
yes this artwork is gary simmons and
it's from teresa and lorenzo fertitta
frank jill and frank futita also lent
two artworks we have worked by from dana
and greg lee
um robin and danny greenspun and
ralph deluca hunter and vanessa campbell
so a lot of las vegas locals that
we are happy to have in this exhibit
absolutely giving us a run for our own
art collections at home yes we're kind
of putting our own art collections to
shame but you guys have to come in here
how
how long can they enjoy the exhibit it's
through february 15th
and we also do have a discount for
locals it's eight dollars
so we're happy to have everybody here we
are closed on tuesdays and wednesdays
but other than that
come by and see us beautiful something
for the family date night whatever you
want to do all right i'll send it back
to you guys
thanks so much rocky and of course
that's why we can enjoy other people's
collections you know let them invest in
the money and we just get to go see them
right brian i like your plan i love that
artwork with the old boxing posters and
joe lewis that was pretty cool